The why is it that we think that the known universe is larger than we can
observe?
Well,
one point is that it's,
um,
expanding and we always see the same radiation out there.
So the glow of the big bang,
but there are some deeper reasons.
And the one from the theory of inflation,
the,
the best way to explain the universe,
the properties that we see is that it's very much bigger than the piece we can
see.
So for example,
we measure space to be what's called flats.
I don't even know how to say what's called flat.
It is flat.
So if you imagine slices of space,
let's say,
imagine slices of them at different times.
So say to slice the universe and say there's a big sheets like this today,
I could tell as a sheet of space.
And then another sheet and another sheet.
And it can,
it can have a geometry.
I can be flat like a tabletop or it could be curved,
uh,
like a sphere or it could be curved in the opposite directions of like a saddle
or a bowl.
And we can measure that.
And when we measure it,
we see it's absolutely flat.
And that's a very unusual thing for it to be like,
um,
it requires,
because what Einstein's theory says is that the,
the shape of space that the curvature of space and determined by the stuff
that's in it,
that's us basically Einstein's theory of general relativity put stuff into space
and it curves and bends it in warm sea and stretches it and so on.
And what we find is that there's precisely the right amount of stuff in the
universe to have a completely flat universe.
And the,
the explanation,
the most favored explanation for that is the university is way bigger than the
piece we can see.
And so it's like looking at piece of the earth.
I,
you look a little one mile square of the earth,
right?
Then it's,
it is flat,
right?
You have to look at big distances kind of evolved at the radius of the earth or
not,
you know,
bigger,
bigger than one kilometer.
Anyway,
on one mile to see the,
actually you're on a curved surface and that's one of the ideas about the
universe and white appears to be the way that it is because it's way,
way bigger.
So we were just talking a little piece and that's why it looks flat and that's
one of the ideas.
Now when you say flat like that,
my,
my brain doesn't understand this because from our perspective when you look up
at the Milky Way,
you see all these stars all over the place.
So if you're saying flat like what,
how much height and what,
what are you saying?
Ah,
so terms of like the way to measure it,
the best way to think about it is not to think of three dimensions of space
because then we can't picture it.
Okay.
But you can think of to like this tabletop and that's all right.
We just forget the other one for now.
And so you know what flat is on this table mean you could define it.
So you could say,
for example,
that if I draw a triangle on the top of the table,
then all the angles add up to 180 degrees.
So that actually defines flats.
If you did that on the surface of the earth with a big triangle,
then the angles wouldn't adopt two under 90 degrees.
Um Oh.
You could draw a circle and say,
what's Pi?
So Pi is the ratio of the circumference of a circle to its diameter.
That's only true on a flat surface is different if the surface is curved.
So you can define flatness.
So when you,
but when,
when you're saying flat and what is the height and what is the width?
Like if you're were talking about it as if it's a table,
there must be some sort of a,
there's a dimension to it,
correct?
Oh yeah.
There's a third dimension of space.
But the,
the same applies.
It's just a generalization of geometry.
Then say you can pay their fighters.
We can picture it in two dimensions,
but you can,
you can draw,
you can quite literally,
you could imagine sending light beams out.
And we do this measurement.
Actually we can look at the,
the,
the disk,
the most distant light we can see,
which is something called the cosmic microwave background radiation,
which is,
if you imagine looking out,
if you look at the Andromeda Galaxy,
which we can see with the naked eye here in la,
you can see that.
So the most distant object you can see with the naked eye,
and it's about two,
2 million light years away or so,
which means the light took 2 million years to get to us.
So it's a long way away,
but it's very big.
So as you look further out into the universe to more and more distant galaxies,
you're looking further back in time cause you look at something that's a billion
light years away.
Then the light took a billion years to get to us.
So you see it as it was a billion years in the past.
And we can actually look so far out that we can see almost back to 13.8 billion
years ago,
which is very close to the big bang.
So we can look to light that began its journey before they were galaxies.
And that's the,
the oldest light in the universe,
which is,
by the way,
one of the,
one of the pieces of evidence,
when people say,
I don't believe in the big bank,
the answer is,
well,
you can see it.
Sorry.
It just,
that you can see,
we have pictures of it.
Um,
that light,
it turns out that there are some structures are ripples in that light,
um,
which we can use as a ruler.
So quite literally as,
as a ruler on the sky.
And then because that light's been traveling through the universe,
we can see how that rule has been distorted as,
as the light has traveled through space.
And so we can infer where the space is flat or curved or how it's warps,
if you like,
just from that measurement.